中大膽周报
欢迎收看中大膽周报
公开版271集
每个星期五都不平静
一个星期五是史上最大的跌点
一个星期五又跌了快要1200点
但是我们也发现
下面到4万3000多点好像有支撑
上面过不到4万6
就有一个锅盖
到底我们现在该如何因应
我想投资人现在信心可能有点低喔
現在信心可能有點低喔
沒錯
我相信你信心低迷
所以呢
我記得上禮拜
之前的大跌
歷史上的最大的跌點
禮拜晚之後
我們上一集錄影片的時候
我看有些網友
好像有點嘲笑我
跌破上身軀視線
這樣子應該走空
怎麼會看會有反彈的時候呢
那我通常都是大跌之後
送温暖
是
这波当中
我想过了一个礼拜之后
大家市场上盘面上告诉你
支撑应该在哪边
这波的低档41967看到
所以4万2那边有支撑
但是呢
我是上礼拜还没看到41967的时候
我跟各位投资朋友提到过
时间在礼拜一礼拜二
会是这波的低点
有没有
有
空间4万3以下
找买点
有没有
有
甚至在我们隐藏版
特别我们隐藏版订阅本
还跟各位讲
破42006会破
请问空间跟时间
我都已经讲得那么清楚了
我相信市场上解盘没有解到
我现在那么清楚
我讲在前面
那事实上我们也不是第一次这样子
在台积电法说会还没有召开之前
我也提到家
万一四万六千
这边你要注意
你会发现后来
就如我所预期的
下跌修正
我们也不是这样子
在记得在更早之前的时候
在放完廉价之后
开市的第一天
大家很火热的认为说
大盘会供五万点
我泼你冷水
还没有记得
大家会过五万点
我马上泼你冷水
刚好如果你有听下去的话
48,200点
全部都是卖到最高点
所以一路走来
我就是会跟各位投资朋友
在高点我不跟市场上嗨
我会提醒你要先卖
在转折点的时候
我会适当提醒你
你不要过度的期待
市场上看的所谓的利多
同样的人在过度的
所谓的市场上看利空的时候
我告诉你
你一定要先踩煞车
否则我相信有一些的网友
应该会去做
跌破上升趋势界
这个就要赶快去加空
刚好加空
你刚好就被修理这一两千点的位置
坦白讲呢
二三十年前的话
我可能也是这样子
我可能会是这样子
但是呢
那毕竟那时候是做表层的
看技术分析
看表层的
经过二三十年之后
后来已经慢慢会学会到不是看线图去研判是你要先去研判哪个点位置到會出現這樣的狀況雖然包括你長久在看YouTube的投資朋友
應該很清楚
在3月的時候敢大膽跟你講
3萬2以下找買點
到這一波的48,200點的附近
叫你賣出去
全部都是不是按照我所規劃的
那我想這個畢竟我
二三十年啊
工作那麼樣子
修练的功力能够往上提升
不过我还是
我还是中等
中等实力
后面那些高层
更厉害
因为我觉得你很细腻
我们算是周报
一个礼拜才一次
但是说实话
有时候看中长线
一个礼拜还是一个很短的变化
但周大胆总是很负责的
希望就把每一个礼拜的变化
都提早跟大家说
我觉得周大胆
你给自己太大的责任感了
但是我觉得大致上的准确度
以及像我最近看到有些订阅户
是已经订我们超过两年
因为我们大概是两年又八个月左右的订阅的这个时间
有人可以跟到两年以上
我觉得他就是很信任您的判断
对
所以呢
他一直相信我判断
礼拜一看到我们的周围
礼拜天看我们的这个中大阪周围报
礼拜一看我们的新推荐个股
礼拜一在大阪市场上很恐慌的时候
他买进去相信我
结果呢
礼拜一涨停板
礼拜二涨停板
这礼拜最高曾经来到三四十趴
所以我还是老话一句
每一档股票适当去做配置的时候
其实它都会有一些
有机会去做获利
那我想这一波来讲
这个大盘跌破上升的趋势线
那我个人认为说
会拉长整理的时间
投信近期有连续买超
不过它的买超已经变小了
但拉回我还是认为不要悲观
量能不增
我认为高档将会持续进行哲理
反复挑战四万五千点
上礼拜我们提到过
这波大盘会反弹到
四万五千点附近来挑战
四万五千点的关卡
最后缩盘
盘中高点
等于来到四万五千三百点
是不是按照我所预计
你不发现
礼拜一跟你讲
礼拜一礼拜二
会出现时间点的
所谓的底部位置
连反弹的高点位置
都跟你讲预期的差不多
我上次还跟你讲
四万五千点的关卡
四三六五零
然后四六三五零
這都算是45000點的關卡
你看禮拜五的收盤多少點
就是在45000點關卡的下緣
所以後面那些高手比我厲害的
但是我只是會希望在這邊
跟各位講多一點
那我們待會會在隱藏版會再講一些
在我們看中線支撐
外資的賣超不到
最近賣超不到
不過指數拉回的時候
他空單沒有明顯下降
雖然投信買超跟客室買盤也進場
所以我認為大盤拉回之爭
我從44500下修到43500
稍微微幅下修
投信晉級不決成本
我們大概抓應該就在44000點左右周的大漲從過去2000點之後之後的獲利調節模式已經改變了怎麼說呢你會發現這個禮拜或上個禮拜已經開始出一些狀況就是
州的你想要獲利
以前是大涨完之後修正
現在什麼
先大跌完之後
你才能夠賺到大跌之後的跌升盤
現在就倒過來
所以模式是不一樣
所以我建議各位投資朋友
我們現在把
45000點以上的持股
會把它調整大概將近50%左右
那過去我是認為要六七成
希望把它調整到50%
那過去的是
8218那個黑黑太多太大量
所以我認為以盤代碟會延續盤整
盤整
長線的支撐從之前的四萬三千年
下丘到四萬兩千五
如果拉回到這裡
比重降到六到七成
我之前是八到九成
那之所以會怎麼樣
如果敢大碟大碟
你手中有充分的資金
就比較能夠隨時能夠有
充容的去做佈局
所以我想這部分
在這禮拜我這邊會做一個調整的部分
資金比重
坦白講
投資朋友如果很長期在看我的YouTube
這種行情過五萬點
我早就沒有再提到過五萬點
五萬點早晚會來
但絕對不是這時候
時間點也不是這時候才跟你講
我解盤通常不是說
今天大漲才跟你講
今天大跌是怎樣
我通常是連續性的
我們先來看一下
6月14號第259期
我之前也提到過了
川席會完之後
兩個月
就是後20天跟後40天
沒有什麼太大行情
5月15號
當時候收盤在41172
如果按照這樣的情況的話
後40天完之後
差不多現在這個時間
是不是現在的指數
前我當時候
這個版本是一模一樣的
當時候提到過
7月中旬的時候
大概會落外4萬到4萬6
回頭來看
你會發現哪有五萬點
所以我之前就已經跟泼各位冷水
所以我希望我用不同的角度
來提醒投資朋友
希望你能夠聽得進去
那第二月二十一號第兩百六十一集
我有提到過
我現在都是把我之前的版本
都拿出來跟你講
我不是馬後炮
我記得現在也跟各位提到過
第三季上漲距離沒有比較高
大概只有五成
然後呢
過去能夠連續攝氏線連漲三季的
也只有2019年
而那个季度也就涨0.92%
换句话说
如果第二季缩盘在46126点
你希望能不能大涨到哪边去
而且上次我们提到过
上半年如果涨幅超过10%以上
第三季百分百下跌
所以当时我也跟你提到过
46300多点
46500点
或甚至快接近50000点
你都不要去追
那我想最近我还是
就是再提示
第三季大漲都不要去追
你要利用下個禮拜
如果大盤有在高檔回到四萬五千點左右
你的高檔降低你的手中的持股比例的部分
我想這邊會跟各位講喔
坦白講這個月的大盤行情變化也說真的應該跌破所有的人眼鏡坦白講我一點也不覺得意外為什麼要放4萬商文件的人進場我們要看一下6月的時候
九大頭顧看今年台股下半年的高點
大致上都認為5萬點有壓力
不到一個月就快達到了
4、7、39、5差200點
同樣大多數人的頭顧也認為
低點4萬點將來到
不到一個月來到4、1、9、6、7
1967也差200點
所以高點差200點快點看到
低點差快200點看到
所以為什麼上次投資朋友你說
來到42000多點
43000的時候
你為什麼不看悲觀
這麼多的投顧有專業的
我相信我們這些同業
大家評估的評價基礎
我們大概知道
因為我在這個圈子有帶9
我大概知道他的評價基礎
所以你要相信那個部分的
所謂的自身性
那目前來講的話
一個月已經看到上下半年了
波動高低點了
快看到了像這個部分
到目前為止
玉山頭庫目前是看高點最準
他是看48000到5萬點
當然是以目前為止
第一個月
下半年的第一個月
上次我們這個版本
6月21號第261集
如果你有上期再看看
我當時有畫一個叫做
積極跟穩健以43000
然後39500點以下
叫超級穩健
叫超級穩健就是很難看得到
46,500以上叫做超級積極的嘛
你也很充的人你就在那邊
所以呢原則上46,500以上
我早就一直建議投資朋友
把手中的支付比例要降到五成或六成左右
所以我看到很開心有些投資朋友
或者隱藏版的訂閱戶
真的有聽我的話
他在那個46,000、47,000、48,000
陸續賣掉
他現在充裕的資金可以買
然後來到上個禮拜的43,000以下
最後一筆把一些穩健的資金放進去
所以在這波當中
來回都可以做很多的順性操作
坦白講手中目前資金是應該蠻充費的
所以講有關於更細節的部分
我想我會在我們的隱藏版再講更清楚
因為七月跟八月這段時間
會是在這波當中操作難度比較高
我會把這部分留在隱藏版的客戶
好 因為我們做這個松大膽週報
已經一段時間了
从台股1万多点
看到4万多点
这中间有足足将近3万点
来回的波折真的不少
包括像去年的对等关税
我想这应该是最大最大的一个冲击了
所以短线上面有一些修正
真的也不用悲观
可是也不要盲目乐观
这段时间操作就是要回归到比较细腻
而钟大胆就是一个比较细腻的人
所以我们会把更多的操作细节
放在我们的VIP里面
给大家做参考
刚刚也稍微剧透了
上禮拜真的找到了一檔很逆式的标股喔
也会在 VIP 里面持续的帮大家做追踪
那我会把订阅的连结放在留言的第一则
欢迎大家来 VIP 找我们吧